peuvent grand débat sur la réforme des
retraites puisqu'elle Isabelle vorne va
la présenter cet après-midi avec nous
pour en débattre trois sénateurs bonjour
Xavier la comédie bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine pour présenter la
majorité présidentielle René Paul Savary
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sénateurs de la Marne membre des
République 1 et Corinne Ferret bonjour
merci c'est natrice du Calvados membre
du groupe socialiste on va évidemment
longuement débattre de cette réforme de
ces pistes de réforme pour le moment
avec vous puisque c'est le jour J cet
après-midi 17h30 Elizabeth borne
présentera donc son projet on va voir
les options qui tiennent la corde avec
Mathias ça reste
Olivier Marleix avait donné le ton la
semaine dernière cette réforme se fera
avec les républicains ou ne se fera pas
pour éviter d'avoir à utiliser un énième
49-3 sur un sujet aussi brûlant c'est un
projet de loi très estampillé et que
devrait présenter ce mardi Elisabeth
borne a priori il y aura besoin d'un
compromis ce compromis il ressemblera
probablement à ce que y compris le Sénat
à travailler pendant de nombreuses
années et qui votent régulièrement dans
cette dans cette chambre donc je pense
que c'est une bonne chose
je laisserai la première ministre faire
les annonces autre condition imposées
par la droite pour donner son vote que
l'augmentation des pensions minimales à
1200 euros s'applique également aux
retraités actuels une solution déjà
soutenue par une partie de la majorité
présidentielle c'est un impact
budgétaire qui est important il faut pas
le minorer c'est 2,7 milliards d'euros
de dire que c'est pas seulement les
nouveaux retraités mais aussi ceux qui
sont déjà mais je crois que c'est
important parce que on a souvent une
fausse image de ceux qui sont déjà à la
comme si finalement c'était presque des
nantis c'est pas le cas pour les mesures
compensatoires le gouvernement devrait
proposer la réintégration de certains
critères de pénibilité ou encore un
index senior que les entreprises de plus
de 55 salariés devront publier
les abattes après le cet après-midi ça
ressemble fortement à ce que votre Sénat
depuis des années le gouvernement vous
aura lieu à rallier la position des
sénateurs
une position de majorité de sénatoriales
partagées avec le groupe Alliance
Centriste depuis un certain nombre
d'années tant mieux ça veut dire que la
copie est bonne et que de temps perdu
voilà ce que je regrette c'est
véritablement ça on a tourné autour du
pot depuis 5 ans pour arriver finalement
à ce qu'on proposait et qui a toujours
été refusé donc tant mieux si on a une
réforme qui correspond à nos aspirations
c'est pour les français qu'on l'a fait
ça veut dire que si ces pistes se
confirment vous votre respect sans
hésitation mais on va voir quels sont à
côté de ça les mesures parallèles par
rapport à parce qu'on peut pas demander
des efforts supplémentaires aux Français
sans avoir un certain nombre de mesures
à côté qui permettent de rendre cette
réforme acceptable me semble-t-il donc
il y a des dispositions à prendre vous
savez le diable se niche dans les
détails donc c'est dans les détails que
on va pouvoir faire notre jugement et on
va essayer d'en parler évidemment de ces
détails on a le temps pendant ce débat
Corinne Ferrer est-ce que vous quoi que
disent Elizabeth band cet après-midi ce
sera non il y aura pas de vote de la
part des de la part de notre groupe
alors je reconnais une certaine
cohérence à mon collègue René Paul
Savary le fait à chaque LSS il y a
toujours un amendement pour reculer le
départ là je légale du départ en
retraite pour nous c'est non ça a
toujours été non au moment de de ces
débats budgétaires c'est nous encore
aujourd'hui c'est une réforme totalement
injuste brutale qui va pénaliser les
plus faibles encore une fois il est vrai
que c'est un choix politique je note que
le gouvernement de Monsieur Macron fait
ce choix politique en je dirais tout se
tourner vers
spécialiste proposé et défendaient à
l'époque de Monsieur Hollande donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on est dans
des postures que si on veut pérenniser
notre système de retraite par
répartition il faut qu'on puisse avoir
une masse de travail plus importante et
donc travailler plus longtemps et c'est
accompagné par des progrès nouveau et
c'est progrès nouveau c'est ce que nous
défendons au sein de la majorité
présidentielle c'est effectivement ce
85% du SMIC pour le minimum garanti ça
c'était quelque chose que nous
demandions autour de l'IVG du socle déjà
depuis 2021 et dans la campagne
présidentielle c'est ça a été un
engagement aussi du président de la
République donc on y arrive c'est
puisque nous on demandait aussi et
Aurore Bergé la la repréciser c'est de
pouvoir faire en sorte que le stock en
tout cas ceux qui aujourd'hui sont déjà
à la retraite puissent bénéficier de ce
minimum garanti 1200 euros moi je prends
toujours l'exemple de mon père elle a
travaillé toute sa vie aujourd'hui il a
un minimum de retraite de 900 euros donc
c'est effectivement un vrai progrès de
pouvoir monter à 1200 euros ce minimum
et ça c'est important de le préciser ça
fait partie des points de détails qui
n'en sont pas effectivement
il faut pas leurrer les gens non plus
hein tant mieux que vous soyez rapproché
de cette position c'est dommage de
l'avoir refusé tant d'années je répète
mais 1200 euros c'est pour une carrière
complète à temps plein ça veut dire que
bien sûr mais il y a que la moitié des
personnes qui sont en situation de
faible revenu qui seront touchés par la
mesure donc il faut pas gonfler l'esprit
des gens en vous faisant croire qu'ils
vont avoir le refrain d'où son
verrouiller un certain nombre de
conditions d'autre part pour prendre
comme on dit ceux qui sont déjà à la
retraite il faut recalculer les droits à
la retraite pour certains donc faut être
attentif c'est là-dessus ou je dis que
il va falloir voir la proposition exacte
que l'on va avoir pour prendre en compte
ce type de mesures qui est une mesure
déjà ah ben tout à fait mais ça fait
partie des lignes rouges et dictées
85%, ça fait déjà mais ça peut être
compliqué ça s'adresse à tous parce que
il y a des voix chez vous qui disent
attention aux finances publiques bien
sûr mais on mesure le coup mais l'effort
qui est demandé aux Français à travers
un temps plus longtemps un décalage de
l'âge de départ à la retraite qui doit
être et là aussi c'est important de voir
le colonrier me semble-t-il mené
parallèlement à l'allongement des durées
de cotisation donc accélération de la
réforme Touraine pour avoir une certaine
coïncidence entre le délai les 43 ans et
l'âge de départ fait que on aura me
semble-t-il les moyens de prendre des
mesures de solidarité sinon on ne peut
pas les financer et on va revenir on va
observer on va revenir évidemment
là-dessus je vous laisse répondre
Corinne Ferrer puisque Xavier akovénie
dimanche 11 de la part du Parti social
c'est pas du tout un mensonge il
évoquait la réforme de
du mandat de François Hollande de Madame
Touraine donc cette réforme elle est en
cours pourquoi vouloir accélérer ce
calendrier qui a été acté et posé il n'y
a pas de mensonge quand on dit nous que
l'on maintient notre volonté de
conserver ce cet âge légal à 62 ans
du Parti socialiste la position et ici
nous sommes entre parlementaires et moi
je m'exprime en tant que parlementaire
et je réponds à votre question dans le
débat parlementaire quel sera ma
position qu'elle sera la position du
groupe socialiste ici à l'Assemblée
nationale
du SI au Sénat voilà ce que nous portons
cette réforme et cet âge légal de 62 ans
est en cours pourquoi vouloir accélérer
la réforme Touraine quand je dis que la
réforme voulue par Emmanuel Macron elle
est brutal car imaginez que dans
quelques semaines et j'ai rencontré des
personnes qui devraient partir à la
retraite s'il a la réforme ne se faisait
pas en septembre en octobre et qui ne
savent pas si ils vont pouvoir le faire
qui ne savent pas si leur dossier va
être prêt enfin qu'elle brutalité
soudainement de se dire et bien ce sera
dès cette fin d'été on va rajouter 4
mois 3 mois selon ce que la réforme se
rend on ne fait pas cas non plus des
carrières longues parce que c'est facile
de dire on rajoute deux ans on a besoin
ou trois ans on a besoin d'argent ou les
financements ne sont pas au niveau que
prétend le gouvernement les financements
ça a été dit s'il y a plus d'emplois
avec des rémunérations et des salaires
plus élevés et bien ça fera plus de
cotisations versées pour nos retraites
et c'est pas seulement les retraités de
demain ou les salariés d'aujourd'hui qui
doivent payer on va dire le prix fort
pour mettre en place cette réforme
encore une fois injuste on va revenir
sur la carrière donc je laisse répondre
sur le premier point effectivement qu'il
y a une cohérence par contre du groupe
socialiste au Sénat qui clairement
effectivement et pour 62 ans mais
d'ailleurs c'est une incohérence par
rapport à la position officielle du
parti socialiste porté par Olivier Faure
et du groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
donc c'est là où je notais
d'une incohérence entre les deux groupes
mais enfin jusqu'à preuve du contraire
vous représentez aussi un parti
politique qui a pris des positions
officielles de par la voix de son
premier secrétaire et qui aujourd'hui se
rapproche plus d'une position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'une position de
François Hollande à l'époque je mets mes
jeunesse
avec l'ensemble des groupes de gauche
vous êtes plus responsable et que vous
vous voulez un minimum au minimum rester
sur un statut quo c'est-à-dire 62 ans
sauf que entre-temps il y a eu
effectivement ce rapport du corps qui
certes n'est pas alarmiste mais enfin
bon ils m'ont il pointe quand même un
déficit important de notre système de
retraite dans les années à venir et donc
il faut bien aujourd'hui si on ne veut
pas à la fois baisser les pensions de
retraités actuels et ça je pense que
personne ne le souhaite donc si on veut
pas augmenter si on veut pas augmenter
les cotisations et donc les impôts parce
que ça c'est un engagement du Président
de la République depuis 2017
effectivement il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions de financement René Paul
Savary le disait de financement à la
fois du système actuel mais aussi des
progrès nouveaux que nous voulons mettre
en place et notamment des carrières
longues donc
Savary mais d'abord puisque vous citiez
le rapport du corps un mot sur ce que
dit il se rapporte du corps Alex et oui
le rapport du Conseil d'orientation la
retraite qui publie et bien c'est
prévisions sur l'avenir financier de
notre régime de retraite alors on le
rappelle déjà aujourd'hui notre régime
de retraite de base se porte bien avec
un excédent 2022 d'un milliard d'euros
mais dans la dernière rapport du corps
publié en septembre et bien le déficit
du régime de retraite va se creuser dans
les prochaines années et devrait
atteindre 8,3 milliards d'euros en 2027
et pour les 25 prochaines années le
corps estime qu'il y aura un déficit
d'une dizaine de milliards d'euros
jusqu'au jusqu'à la moitié du siècle
jusqu'aux alentours de 2050 et à partir
de la moitié du siècle le régime de
retraite deviendra excédentaire
repassera à l'équilibre donc ce sont des
prévisions à long terme qu'il faut quand
même prendre avec des pincettes car ça
dépend des différents scénarios projetés
du niveau de croissance et puis il peut
y avoir des événements conjoncturels
comme on l'a vu une épidémie une guerre
qui peut qui peut changer la donne du
coup je vous laisse répondre est-ce que
comme Gabriel Attal vous dites c'est la
réforme ou la faillite c'est ce que de
toute façon c'est clair c'est bien
d'être exprimé mais il faut rappeler que
il y a du déficit en ayant un niveau de
vie moyen des retraités qui va passer
dans les années qui viennent à 85% par
rapport au salaire moyen alors
qu'aujourd'hui il a 103 % ça veut dire
qu'on fabrique des retraités pauvres si
on ne fait rien c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut prendre des mesures
pour en revenir à l'accélération de la
réforme Touran pourquoi on propose ça
parallèlement à la mesure d'âge moi j'ai
proposé cette mesure puisque j'en suis
l'auteur depuis un certain nombre
d'années pourquoi parce que quand vous
augmentez la durée de cotisation et que
vous ne décadez pas l'âge légal les gens
ont tendance à partir à l'âge légal et
non pas toute leur cotisations donc
c'est une fabrique à retraiter pauvre
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
également décaler l'âge de façon à le
faire coïncider au mieux pour que l'on
puisse à travers ces mesures faire des
retraités qui est un niveau de vie
décent et d'autre part en promenant les
mesures le plus tôt possible et je dis
il y a déjà 5 ans de retard c'est
dommage ça permet de maintenir 64 ans
l'âge de départ légal et non pas d'aller
jusqu'au 65 qui est quand même un âge
qui est accepté par les pays européens
voisins donc faut être attentif à cela
et si on prend les mesures maintenant
faut les appliquer de façon à ce que le
l'effet positif de ces mesures puissent
intervenir le plus tôt possible ainsi
même par répartition par définition ne
peut pas être payé par la dette il doit
être équilibré sinon il est remise en
cause c'est pour ça qu'on propose une
réforme depuis nombre d'années quand une
ferraille là-dessus et vous l'avez
compris je l'ai déjà dit nous y sommes
totalement opposés parce que quand on
dit en plus de de
d'augmenter le nombre de cotisations les
années de cotisations vous imaginez
celui ou celle qui a commencé à
travailler à 18 ans ça veut dire que il
faudra aller jusqu'à 64 65 ans
on pourrait parler des carrières longues
parlons-en des carrières longues parce
que aujourd'hui
tous les critères et toutes les
conditions pour bénéficier du dispositif
carrière longue ce qui demain
s'inscrivent encore une fois dans ce
cotisations à partir de 19 ans par
exemple ne remplissent pas tous les
critères des carnets
on risque de fabriquer des retraités
pauvres si on fait pas de réformes mais
pas du tout enfin encore une fois je
veux rappeler à la fois le nombre
d'années de cotisations nécessaires
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir percevoir une
retraite une pension à taux plein si
demain on décale on y rajoute deux ans
voire trois ans en effet la première
ministre parlera aujourd'hui si on y met
en même temps excusez moi
ces années supplémentaires de
cotisations alors non seulement il va
falloir travailler plus longtemps et je
rappelle que dans les personnes qui ont
entre 55 et 64 ans qui aujourd'hui ils
ont a priori en fin de carrière c'est
plus de la moitié d'entre eux qui ne
sont plus en situation
d'activités professionnelles qui sont
soit en invalidité excusez-moi ça
correspond pas au niveau de de d'un
salaire soit au chômage voire perçoivent
le RSA alors ces personnes là vous
croyez que parce que on rajouterait deux
années et bien oui ils vont rester dans
l'emploi d'un baguette magique parce
qu'on ne met la pression que sur les
salariés et bien les employeurs les
maintientront dans l'emploi dans leur
société dans leur entreprise ça n'est
pas vrai donc c'est bien cela et je ne
veux bien je veux aussi parler des
femmes qui sont concernées pour beaucoup
d'entre elles par des carrières hachées
des carrières incomplètes qui vont être
doublement plus encore pénalisé vous
évoquiez ce qui se passe dans nos chez
nos voisins pays européens mais
comparant ce qui est comparable les
problématiques ne sont pas les mêmes et
dans beaucoup de pays les femmes
bénéficient peuvent en tout cas avoir
droit à la retraite bien avant à un âge
trois pays sur 27 non non plus
la Grèce la Grèce et l'Allemagne ou les
sont partent à la retraite à 60 ans on
tient compte des problématiques
s'organiser en prenant en compte la
réalité des choses des nations vous avez
les moyens de financer ce type de mesure
c'est pour ça que il faut faire en sorte
qu'on puisse équilibrer ce système pour
dégager des moyens pour prendre des
mesures de solidarité mais je voudrais
rappeler que aux personnes à qui on va
demander de travailler plus longtemps
effectivement c'est des personnes en
emploi mais c'est un effort qu'elles
font pour financer leur retraite à un
niveau décent par leur cotisations c'est
un système contributif et que l'effort
qui devrait être pris en compte au titre
de la solidarité lui est payé par
l'impôt ça représente déjà 20% du
système au niveau de nos retraites et ça
peut continuer à représenter un certain
nombre de financement correspondant à
des mesures nouvelles prenant en compte
ce type de difficulté parce que on n'est
pas nous sommes pas des personnes
insensibles on sait bien qu'il y a des
personnes qui sont au bord de la route
et pas le fait de changer l'âge qui va
leur changer la vie effectivement il
n'empêche que à travers un système
d'avantage équilibré c'est tout à fait
légitime que ceux qui ont cotisé pendant
un certain nombre d'années encore plus
d'années à l'avenir ils aient une
garantie d'un financement avec un revenu
correct et c'est comme ça qu'on ne
redonnerait confiance aux jeunes sinon
ils vont perdre confiance dans notre
système et alors on passera un système
par capitalisation qui viendra plus du
système par répartition pourquoi pas
personnellement je suis pas spécialement
opposé mais on peut faire en sorte de
trouver quelque chose qui correspondent
à notre modèle social sans en arriver
forcément là
avant de parler déclaration de la
pénibilité on va voir sur la pénibilité
moi je voudrais juste te répondre je
pense effectivement qu'il a raison
aujourd'hui y compris ma génération mais
la génération après moi aussi on entend
beaucoup ces jeunes gens dire bah moi je
n'aurais pas de retraite donc toi vous
la retraite vous savez c'est bien loin
et je pense que l'objectif aussi est
notre responsabilité en tant que
politique c'est de faire en sorte
justement de redonner confiance à la
jeunesse de notre pays en leur disant si
cette réforme nous permettra d'avoir de
maintenir ce système par répartition et
vous aurez une retraite si effectivement
vous cotisez si vous travaillez tout au
long de votre vie et donc c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette réforme des retraites
c'est de faire en sorte de pérenniser
notre système après sur la question de
la pénibilité effectivement il y a il y
a besoin de remettre des critères de
pénibilité que ce soit pas une usine à
gaz peut-être comme nous avions avant
mais en tout cas je pense qu'il est
important et et je précise quand même
que le travail qui a été fait depuis des
mois autour du ministre du travail et du
plein emploi Olivier du socle avec les
partenaires sociaux a abouti quand même
à des progrès nouveaux je pense
effectivement aux revenus
garantis minimum de 1200 euros mais
aussi sur la question de la pénibilité
sur la question des carrières longues et
on peut en parler on va on va en parler
tout ce travail qui a été fait de
concertation qui est parfois été raillé
par les oppositions mais qui a été utile
sans effet de manche je pense que ça
c'est aussi les progrès nouveau qui vont
aboutir dans cette dans cette forme on
va la pénibilité il aurait été bien que
le gouvernement de Monsieur Macron ne
supprime pas aussi critères sur 10 4
critères sur 10 pardon on finit par s'y
perdre je rappelle que le C2P le compte
personnel pénibilité qui a été mis en
place sous le gouvernement de François
Hollande a été dès 2017 à l'arrivée de
d'Emmanuel Macron au pouvoir révisé et
supprimer quatre critères essentiels
dans les critères de pénibilité j'ai
envie de dire que ça démarre mal sur on
va juste on va en parler mais on va en
parler le temps de regarder un reportage
un reportage là dessus le temps de
regarder un reportage justement sur
cette question de la pénibilité Fabien
Ricard nous emmène dans le Pas-de-Calais
à la rencontre d'où viennent du bâtiment
regarde
c'est un chantier de rénovation dans le
Pas-de-Calais Christophe Santerre passe
ses journées perché sur son échafaudage
armée d'un marteau et d'un ciseau à
Pierre un travail de fourmis pour
restaurer les voûtes de ce monastère du
14e siècle
aujourd'hui bon on a rien à démonter
mais quand c'est des grosses pierres
c'est assez lourd à manipuler à 51 ans
Christophe a rouler sa bosse comme
carreleur Masson ou tailleur de pierre
cela fait plus de 30 ans qu'il arpente
les chantiers partout en France il a
entendu parler du projet de réforme des
retraites du gouvernement il ne se voit
pas travailler jusqu'à 65 ans les
semaines de marteau-piqueur tout à 60
ans déjà c'est raide
51 ans quand on en fait des semaines
complètes le soir on est mort
on rentre on se couche pendant ce temps
David joue du marteau-piqueur lui n'a
que 28 ans mais déjà les mêmes
inquiétudes je vois pas 60 ans porter
encore des pierres tout ça comme là je
fais actuellement quand j'ai vu
justement ces augmentations chaque fois
de l'âge de retraite nous actuellement
on sert de poulie électrique pour monter
les pierres je me dis toujours qu'à la
fin c'est trop nous qu'on montera la
poulie électrique parce qu'on pourra
plus monter quoi et pourtant Christophe
et David pourrait bien être frappé par
le report de l'âge légal car les métiers
du BTP sont aujourd'hui exclus du conte
pénibilité un dispositif qui permet de
partir à la retraite deux ans plus tôt à
condition de remplir certains critères
comme l'exposition au bruit ou le
travail de nuit le port de charge
lourdes lui n'est pas pris en compte un
système dénoncé par les syndicats un
exemple il faut travailler 160 heures de
nuit pour avoir accès aux comptes
pénibilité si jamais votre entreprise
vous met 159 heures de nuit vous n'avez
pas le droit au compte pénibilité voilà
c'est ça aujourd'hui et en fait c'est
des expositions individuelles et nous ce
qu'on porte auprès du gouvernement c'est
que on dit c'est pas l'exposition
individuelle qui compte c'est le métier
vous avez un métier pénible vous avez
pas un métier pénible vous avez un
métier qui vous prématurément et que
donc c'est bien le métier qu'il faut
prendre en compte les travailleurs qui
ont des métiers qui usent pourront-ils
partir plus tôt la question reste à
trancher le gouvernement pourrait
choisir de renvoyer cette négociation
aux branches professionnelles
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
ouvriers qui disent mais moi à plus de
60 ans je pourrais plus faire ce métier
mais bien sûr mais on était tous
conscients c'est très délicat c'est pour
ça que je ne pense pas que ça peut être
pas un métier c'est vraiment en fonction
du travail il faut trouver après les les
critères effectivement à définir le
travail pénible on a vu ce reportage
effectivement n'est pas inhumain on va
pas faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps mais il faut dégager des
moyens pour prendre en compte ce type de
mesure et c'est là ce qu'on va voir ce
que propose le gouvernement par rapport
à cela parce que c'est c'est toujours
compliqué
euh apprendre en compte puis alors faut
relativiser hein c'est comme les
carrières longues quand on regarde les
carrières longues et on a quand on
commence les jeunes ils ont pas fait
forcément des métiers pénibles moi je
suis médecin j'étais en carrière longue
parce que les années d'externat ont
compté en trimestre donc vous arrivez à
un âge ou j'aurais pu travailler
enfin peu importe donc ce qui montre
bien que vous prendre en compte l'autre
jour je rencontrais un maçon je lui ai
mis il me paraissait un peu âgé je lui
dis bah alors vous attendez la retraite
il me dit non moi je suis maçon c'est
difficile mais j'aime mon métier
franchement j'ai pas envie de partir
quand vous rencontrez d'autre part un
senior qui a été licencié c'est la pire
des situations moi j'en ai soigné des
seigneurs licenciés il faut pas mettre
il faut vraiment prendre des mesures
pour faire en sorte qu'on maintienne les
seniors en emploi donc faut changer
notre culture notre vision vis-à-vis de
ça il faut leur proposer des métiers
alternants différents moins pénibles de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent continuer à
avoir pignon sur rue dans la société à
travers l'emploi ou alors comment je
vois les choses on va parler des
seigneurs sur la pénibilité est-ce qu'il
faut réintégrer les critères de
pénibilité qui ont été supprimés moi je
pense qu'il faut effectivement des
critères de pénibilité métier par métier
et post par poste quasiment il faut il
faut de la dentelle pourquoi parce que
on voit bien que ce qui était prévu
auparavant c'était voilà métier par
exemple sur le bâtiment je prends
l'exemple du bâtiment quand on est
commercial dans le bâtiment c'est pas la
même pénibilité quand on est manœuvre
sur les chantiers et donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi faire de la dentelle sur ces
questions de pénibilité et c'est pour ça
que d'ailleurs y compris les partenaires
sociaux ont du mal à se mettre d'accord
sur les questions de pénibilité c'est
d'avoir pour ça que ça n'a pas
fonctionné auparavant c'est souvent
inapplicable pour les entreprises et
c'est peu lisible pour les salariés donc
il faut quelque chose de lisible qui
soit facile à appliquer pour les
entreprises et qui puissent vraiment
permettre à ceux qui ont un travail dur
pénible de pouvoir avoir des une décote
on va dire sur les annuités de travail
et rendez-vous compte qu'avec cette
réforme non seulement donc je pense
qu'il faut absolument revenir sur
l'ensemble des critères tels qu'ils
existaient avant 2017 les représentants
des salariés organisations syndicale le
disent bien l'exemple qui est pris sur
le bâtiment on est un peu dans la
caricature enfin quand même pas exagéré
entre celui qui va vendre des immeubles
et celui qui joue après jour heure après
est au travail dur pénible vous n'avez
pas me dire le contraire on doit pouvoir
comparer et reconnaître cette pénibilité
mais mais non parce que tu fais le
distinguo entre le commercial dans le
bâtiment et le maçon dans le bâtiment
on est sur des métiers qui sont
extrêmement pénibles il y a ceux aussi
du service à la personne etc mais
rendez-vous compte je pense que là c'est
basique aujourd'hui vous remplissez
quelques critères à tous mais vous
permet de partir deux ans plus tôt donc
à 60 ans au lieu de 62 ans
mathématiquement si on recule l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 64 voire 65 ans
vous partiriez les salariés par nos
partirait deux ans plus tôt donc c'est
plus 60 ans c'est 62 ans donc il
travailleront plus il travailleront plus
tout en étant toujours dans des
conditions de pénibilité et des
conditions de travail qui sont
insupportables et même s'il souhaite
pouvoir travailler plus longtemps un
moment donné vous êtes bien placé pour
le savoir c'est le corps aussi qui dit
le corps humain qui dit bah non je ne
peux plus quand vous êtes cassé fracassé
et bien c'est comme cela qu'on retrouve
une bonne partie de ces salariés en
invalidité et qui même s'il souhaitaient
bon travailler continuer et bien ils ne
peuvent plus alors quand on leur propose
que demain et où cela était dit demain
ils devront même s'il remplissent ces
critères de pénibilité de toute façon
travailler deux ans de plus je pense que
ça c'est inacceptable et inintendables
et c'est là moi où j'attends ce que va
nous proposer
on peut prendre en compte ce type de
difficulté ça se fait dans d'autres pays
donc il faut regarder c'est pour ça que
dans ce que nous proposions à travers
mon amendement depuis des années nous
donnions un an de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux pour définir tout ça
parce que sont les partenaires sociaux
qui sont mieux passées
de la réforme mais c'est la concertation
des partenaires sociaux de façon à ce
que on trouve ensemble un certain nombre
de dispositifs pour prendre en compte
ces difficultés mais si on ne fait rien
c'est pas pour autant qu'on les réglera
le problème de la pénibilité du travail
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
que la retraite les dispositifs de
retraite doivent atténuer justement les
différences qui peut y avoir à travers
les différents métiers et donc il faut
une politique sur le travail qu'il soit
digne de ce nom là pour la convertir
ensuite au moment de la retraite
Savary il faut laisser plus de temps à
la concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux sur ces questions est-ce que là
ça va trop vite sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il y a besoin de mettre la réforme
sur la question de l'équilibre
budgétaire sur les progrès nouveau et
ensuite effectivement et la première
ministre émise du travail Olivier du
socle on nous rappelait il y aura encore
les négociations par branche qui seront
mise en place notamment sur la question
de l'emploi des seniors sur cet index
qui est voulu par le gouvernement et
dont Olivier du sott a indiqué que il
faudrait valoriser les bonnes pratiques
et sanctionner celle qui qui ne sont pas
bonnes et donc je pense que sur la
question de l'emploi des seniors il y a
un vrai travail qui est fait qui doit
être impulsé par le gouvernement et qui
soit ensuite remis en responsabilité
dans les négociations de branche avec
les partenaires sociaux et donc c'est
pareil sur la question de la pénibilité
il y a la réforme et il y a ensuite les
négociations par branche c'est tout
l'enjeu aujourd'hui des prochains des
prochains mois c'est là qu'on attend les
propositions parce que si la réforme est
proposée à travers un projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale
rectificatives on peut pas apprendre en
compte tout ça et on ne va pas signer
non plus un chèque en blanc à la
première ministre en disant on verra
tous ces problèmes plus tard bien sûr
donc il faut quand même qu'on ait des
avancées une liste une piste une vision
ce que je reproche ce gouvernement
régulièrement c'est l'absence de vision
s'ils avaient eu cette vision là
partagez il y a 5 ans on n'en serait pas
là relu pendant les congés les trois
tomes de l'étude d'impact de la réforme
proposée par par delvoy il y a 5 ans
c'est très intéressant mais voir les
critiques qui faisait sur notre système
par répartition pour nous imposer un
système universel par point aujourd'hui
ce sont les arguments contraires pour
défendre le système par répartition ce
sont ces tergiversation qui
m'impressionne dans nombreux domaines et
qui font que on est attentif et on ne
votera pas ce ce texte à n'importe
quelle condition nous serons vigilants
un mot peut-être Alex sur ce que vous en
parliez tout à l'heure sur ce qui se
passe chez nos voisins européens
effectivement alors dans tous les pays
de l'Union européenne il y a un régime
de retraite par répartition mais elle
est mode de calcul des pensions de
retraite diffère en fonction des pays on
peut distinguer en gros trois modes de
calcul d'une pension de retraite d'abord
un régime par annuité c'est ce qui est
utilisé en France c'est à dire que la
pension est calculée en fonction du
nombre d'annuités d'années de cotisation
ensuite il y a le régime par point
c'était le régime qu'Emmanuel Macron
voulait instaurer dans son premier
quinquennat en vain donc le régime par
point commence à fonctionner cotisations
versées au fil de la carrière sont
convertis en point à la valeur du point
peut varier chaque année et la pension
de retraite est calculée en fonction du
nombre de points accumulés et puis le
troisième mode de calcul en Europe c'est
le régime des comptes nationales les
comptes nationales ça veut dire que les
travailleurs accumulent un capital
virtuel qui est en gros la somme de leur
cotisation et à la fin de leur carrière
au moment de leur retraite et bien la
pension et calculer en fonction de ce
capital mais via quand même un taux de
conversion qui dépend de leur espérance
de vie alors où sont utilisés ces
régimes et bien dans 15 pays européens
c'est le régime par annuité dont la
France le système par point est instauré
dans 5 pays européens dont l'Allemagne
et puis les comptes nationales sont
utilisés notamment en Italie et en Suède
un mot rapidement sur les âges les
différents âges de départ mais oui sur
les différents âges alors on peut dire
que la France est l'un des pays où on
peut partir légalement le plus tôt à la
retraite à 62 ans c'est le cas aussi en
Suède en Slovaquie il y a quand même
certains pays européens vous en parliez
ou à les femmes peuvent partir plus tôt
que les hommes c'est le cas en 60 ans en
Autriche en Pologne 61 ans en Roumanie
et en Bulgarie en moyenne dans la
majorité des États c'est un âge légal de
départ à 65 ans mais dans certains pays
et bien ça va plus loin jusqu'à 67 ans
en Italie au Pays-Bas et puis au
Portugal on est à 66 ans et 7 mois et on
voit dans des pays comme ça que les
retraités retravaillent après parce que
ça fait des retraités pauvres on voit
que la va décaler son aile de départ
est-ce que vous avez omis de dire
également excusez-moi c'est que les
régimes complémentaires dans tous ces
pays-là sont des régimes par
capitalisation et non pas par
répartition contrairement à nous nous en
France on a mis tous nos œufs dans le
même panier c'est l'ensemble des bases
complémentaires non non c'est pas une
forcement c'est l'histoire pourquoi pas
mais faut voir derrière comment financer
ça veut dire que si on prend pas les
mesures si on prend pas des mesures en
équilibrer le système et le système
tombe un système quand vous mettez comme
ces pays-là ils ont mis moins de
cotisations des retraites de base plus
basses et c'est chacun vous laissez de
la place pour que chacun puisse faire
proprement sa retraite nous nous avons
un régime très solidaire c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire comprendre aux Français
que pour l'équilibrer il y a besoin
effectivement que chacun amène sa pierre
à l'édifice
conclusion là dessus du débat on aurait
eu encore beaucoup de choses à dire mais
malheureusement on arrive au thème de ce
débat au terme de ce débat
conclusion en conclusion je le redis
c'est très fort mais injuste extrêmement
dur et brutal pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens je rappelle que la majorité
des Français ils sont opposés je
rappelle que parce que ça a été dit on
nous dit oui mais Emmanuel Macron
l'avait indiqué dans son programme de
campagne il a été élu pour ça rappelle
quand même que 42% des Français qui ont
voté pour lui l'ont fait pour faire
barrage au rassemblement national donc
il y avait pas un blanc sain et à chaque
en blanc donné pour la réforme des
retraites pour la réforme des retraites
il a dit lui-même Emmanuel Macron le
soir de sa victoire en disant je
conscience de cela et cette
responsabilité m'accombe alors là dessus
écoutons les Français écoutons et
comment on va dire soyons aussi au fait
de du contexte aussi dans lequel nous
aujourd'hui enfin nous sortons d'une
crise sanitaire nous sommes en plein
dans une crise économique voire sociale
les Français sont extrêmement inquiets
avec une inflation galopante avec le
coût de l'énergie qui ne cesse de
progresser et il continue et vous
continuez à être dans cet état anxiogène
de leur dire peut-être que vous partiez
de la commune on ne sait pas comment
donc le temps est venu de remettre à
plein les choses et de remettre en
question cette réforme et en 30 secondes
en 30 secondes oui juste sur la question
des carrières longues parce que c'était
important aussi d'en parler il y a un
nouveau dispositif qui sera présenté par
la première ministre aujourd'hui pour
permettre effectivement de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans de
pouvoir partir à partir de 62 ans pareil
avant de ça sera 58 ans pour ceux qui
sont qui ont commencé à travailler à 16
ans il y a aussi la prise en compte de
l'apprentissage et donc ça c'est aussi
important c'est tout ça oui non non
je vous ai pas interrompu aujourd'hui on
pourra partir à 60 ans quand on a
commencé à travailler à 18 ans c'est un
nouveau dispositif qui est intégré dans
les dispositifs existants notamment pour
ceux qui ont travaillé à partir de 16
ans pourront partir toujours à 58 ans et
pareil 20 ans pour 62 ans donc ça c'est
des dispositifs qu'on maintient et qu'on
renforce notamment pour pour les
apprentis
[Musique]